vous avez vu où on en est mais pourquoi
on en est nous voyez on est ici vous
êtes là
Macron a fait une halte surprise sur le
marché de Dole dans le Jura pour un bain
de foule vous dites sur les chiffres
vous vous dites beaucoup de bêtises tous
les jours tous les jours et depuis 5 ans
non seulement je n'ai favorisé aucune de
ces associations mais par ailleurs dans
un premier temps on m'a même accusé je
cite de copinage je n'ai aucun ami aucun
copain aucun proche parmi aucun des
lauréats du fond Marianne c'est 100
jours l'objectif je l'ai dit hier et je
le redis c'est de montrer aux français
qu'on entend leur préoccupations et
qu'on met toute notre énergie pour
apporter des réponses pour la première
ministre programme mon avocate mettre en
main conquis attaque en diffamation
toutes les personnes ou plateformes en
ligne qui m'imputent un délit de
favoritisme parce que nous avons tous
les éléments pour je vous ai montré que
c'est faux c'est une souffrance
maintenant s'infliger des discours
d'Elisabeth borne c'est déprimant
possible on a une première ministre qui
ne décide de rien qui manifestement n'a
même pu le soutien du président de la
République qui va jusqu'à humilier sa
première ministre en la faisant
s'exprimer non pas des locaux de
Matignon mais des locaux de l'Élysée qui
vient nous expliquer qu'elle ne fera
strictement rien Emmanuel Macron qui est
maintenant arrivé au château de Joux
dans le Doubs une visite dans le cadre
du 175e anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavage sur place un comité
d'accueil attendez bruyamment vous avez
des grandes entreprises de
transformation des grandes qui ont fait
monter les prix au début parce que leurs
intrants montés et là ça baisse pas donc
eux ils s'en mettent ils ont pris des
marches terribles oui je partage mot
pour vous ce que dit le président de la
République et sans faire de grandes
confidences il m'est arrivé à nombreuses
reprises de dire à des grands patrons
franchement est-ce que vous avez besoin
de ça rémunération à propos d'inflation
La Voix du Nord a fait les calculs en 16
mois le chariot test du journal en
supermarché chercher à Bondy de 26 euros
et 59 centimes il est passé de 120 à
plus de 146 euros il s'agit pas
simplement de présenter un texte de loi
nous l'avons fait le gouvernement l'a
fait il a mis sur le bureau du Sénat
révélique pour l'instant un projet de
loi que nous avons retiré à la demande
du président du Sénat qui pensait que
c'était pas le moment d'avoir un débat
sur ces sujets que ça pouvait créer des
divisions et c'est évidemment faux le
vrai problème de la borne aujourd'hui
sur le sujet migratoire c'est sa propre
majorité ça n'est pas les républicains
et nous l'avons dit avec beaucoup de
clarté nous sommes prêts nous avons des
lignes claires et d'ailleurs Olivier
Marleix l'a annoncé d hier puisque
madame borne veut nous mettre le nous
faire porter le chapeau nous allons
déposer notre propre texte évidemment il
faut qu'on ait enfin qu'on est la
possibilité d'avoir une majorité au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée et de toute façon
comme je comme je l'ai dit hier ce débat
nous souhaitons au plus tard d'avoir à
l'automne c'est un aveu d'échec mais je
préfère ça plutôt que d'accélérer une
loi d'ici l'été comme le monsieur Macron
on s'oriente vers une mobilisation
historique ce sont les mots des
renseignements territoriaux dans une
autre rédigée le 24 avril jusqu'à 100000
personnes sont attendues dans le cortège
parisien dont 2500 à 5000 élément
radicaux c'est la première fois que
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
appellent à manifester ça sera familial
populaire festif puisque je rappelle que
dans les cortèges syndicaux la sécurité
des manifestants et manifestante et
toujours assurée le Stade de France est
à vendre le Paris Saint-Germain et pour
l'heure le seul candidat déclaré un plan
B pour le club qatari à défaut de
pouvoir acheter le Parc des Princes que
la mairie de Paris refuse de lui céder
reste aussi à convaincre les supporters
très attachés au stade historique du PSG
réponse de l'État sur ce dossier courant